sierra let me if i want to step by the  ball please  [Music]  i sure hope this poor young man knows  what he's getting into  we'll try to help him out  i'll do a sir on  sir  that's what i'm talking to and i'll be  glad to  mr mitchell  please i'm pulling you over because you  did a california stop back at that  stoplight when you finally came to stop  and it's three quarters way out in the  road somebody could hit you  i'll tell you what uh  what about the coffin  is anything illegal in the truck all  right  everybody stepping out for me  all right  still want to do this i couldn't get  that squad  [Applause]  [Music]  how you doing your name police ma'am  sierra let me focus on the stop the call  please yes  everything you knew or anything will  hurt me folks and stick me in the  vehicle no it's not i might walk him  back here with me  baby  [Music]  you know what's going on  you're on camera  i got it